now we briefly touched on this next
story last night but it was so enraging
that I thought it deserved a longer
conversation it's so incredible that I
have to offer this amendment it almost
sounds like the domain of Science
Fiction that the federal government
would put a kill switch in vehicles that
would be the judge the jury and the
Executioner on such a fundamental right
as the right to travel freely now this
isn't about protecting people it's about
controlling your every move at least
when you're in a vehicle and it's
something that the left and the federal
government want you to kind of get used
to House Republicans in 19 house
Democrats and 19 Republicans voted
against Thomas massie's amendment that
would defund a federal kill switch
mandate which means that all cars
manufactured starting in
2026 will now have a way for authorities
to monitor your driving and then cut
power to your car oh what could go wrong
with that that joining me now Kentucky
Congressman Thomas Massie Congressman
now I I think gee H when some of us were
driving we needed to because we were
necessary essential employees but we
were driving during coid and they didn't
know know we were necessary employees
maybe they would have hit the kill
switch on us who knows yeah you you know
people said I'm a conspiracy theorist
for saying this is in the legislation
but I actually had to read the Democrat
the bill that they passed two years ago
they passed this in 2021 as part of a
1039 page Bill to require that your car
can monitor your driving performance and
if it thinks you're not driving well it
can disable your vehicle imagine you're
a mom with kids in the car and you
swerved for a deer and then you pulled
over for an emergency vehicle to go by
and you've only got one swerve left I
mean how Terri before it shuts you down
and takes you to the side of the road my
question is how do do you appeal your
conviction when you're sitting at the
side of the road with a car that won't
run who knows where
stranded here's your colleague from
Michigan of course Auto industry capital
of the world representative Debbie
Dingle she reacted to your
Amendment we need to stop drunk driving
by making impairment prevention
technology standard in new vehicles it
does not mandate kill switches or allow
data collection that invades vehicle
occupants privacy I protect data privacy
Vehicles probably more than the sponsor
of this does it's ridiculous and it
doesn't monitor how you
drive uh Congressman please respond to
those malfus
tones well she needs to read the bill
that she voted for that's the problem it
does and after she said that I did read
her the Bill here's the other thing this
isn't a breathalyzer the 31 States
already have ignition interlock devices
where if you've been convicted of a DUI
you have to blow through that in order
to start your car that's not what this
is now this bill also has the ability it
says that car manufactures need to
somehow passively monitor the air in the
car to see if you've been drinking the
problem with that is what if you're the
designated driver and you're trying to
get somebody home who's had too much to
drink there's so many ways this could go
wrong it's basically a backseat driver a
nanny and to her point about privacy I'm
worried about that as well how do you
know if somebody driving well on the
road they're on unless you know which
road they're on so you need to know
their location who has access to this
information is there going to be a
camera that's watching your face as you
drive to make sure you're looking at the
road who gets that data and do they need
a warrant yeah where it's it's unclear
to me where the data is stored I mean
they're claiming it's not but there was
a surprising vote for four-year
Amendment um maybe not that surprising
if she's a real liberal uh Alexandria
Casia Cortez so she's with you finally
we got some bipartisan agreement even if
the amendment failed I talked to her
about it she had civil liberties
concerns genuine civil liberties
concerns she knows this is a violation
of the Fourth Amendment but think about
this there's 19 Republicans who are to
the authoritarian left of AOC now so
that's my question is not why did I get
a few Democrats to vote for it but why
were there Republicans who want to keep
this mandate in cars for any for any
this regulation we have enough we're
getting killed by regulations in this
country Congressman thank you for
alerting us to this we really appreciate
it hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere
else